for those of you that may not know
Elizabeth is a nickel Fellowship
recipient how does it feel to have come
this far in that amount of time there
really are not words I'm it's quite
emotional to be back here in this
theater and upstairs where we had our
committee lunch that today three years
ago when I won that fellowship with my
four fellow fellows and and then you
know had the big presentation here and
to be here what this movie is pretty
profound
I don't know how it all happened but
here we are so well we're so happy to
have you back on our stage in Hollywood
lifecycle it's pretty it probably feels
a little fast from 2015 to now here you
are back with that script back on the
screen that maybe you've lived with it
so long it doesn't feel fast but I think
that's fantastic thank you so much it
was a seven-year endeavor I think since
the day that I wrote the first draft and
it was an all-consuming seven years
endeavor so it feels incredibly short
but also incredibly long um a long
letting go of something that I wasn't
ready to let go of in the first place
so yeah yeah but thank you I also read
an interview with you where you said the
inspiration for this story hit me like
lightning so would you tell us kind of
exactly what happened and what was that
thunderbolt sure I was I my grandmother
was diagnosed with Alzheimer's when I
was 21 and she she battled the disease
for 17 years she just passed away in
June but I was so unexpectedly taken by
the fact that we laughed so much you
know that that it was I just I was so
devastated by that diagnosis and I just
thought it was like our fun was over how
could anything ever be fun and funny
again and and growing up in Chicago with
a bunch of uncles
like T's to us all so much and we
laughed our way through everything
except Church to lose that was
devastating and I just was surprised at
how funny everything was but and so I
had been kind of musing about something
I wanted to like write her and capture
that spirit that tone something about it
how you know how funny and then all of a
sudden she turn on a dime and break your
heart and then my grandfather died
really suddenly very much like in the
film you know she was right at that
place where he could no longer really
take care of her and no longer really
deny that he couldn't take care of her
and he just died not quite as suddenly
as in the movie but he just passed away
I'm a broken heart I think and I was at
his funeral listening to the eulogy my
mom gave which was very similar to this
eulogy and just been like well this is a
movie someone here is making this movie
and then looking around the theater or
the theater the church in Illinois or
you know looking for who that person
would be it didn't occur to me then that
it would be me
I thought it was supposed to be somebody
else and then I supposed to like run up
to them and say oh you're making this
movie didn't you know and it wasn't
until six months later when I I thought
I don't think anyone's doing this but I
decided to write that draft that first
draft so well that's the story yeah
Robert if ever a character was suited to
an actor or vice-versa it is you and
Bert
and I'd like to know when you read the
script for the first time what did you
think and what did you feel you know I
have only seen this picture twice and
you've seen it a lot of times but I am
was struck by how good every actor in
this picture was start with Tyson
god she was good and so it's Blythe and
so was Hillary and Michael I am just
amazed at how good the actors
and the reason that they are one of the
reasons they are good two of the reasons
they are good is because you wrote a
wonderful movie and when I read it I
could hear it in my mind I could speak
those words they come from Chicago and
I'm from Rochester New York which is not
that far away it's along the Great Lakes
the the accent is very similar and and
because you have a real hmm it's a grace
that a lot of directors do not have and
it gives the actor the feeling that the
words they are saying are their own that
they are the authors of those words and
they aren't of course you wrote him you
know there were tiny little things that
might have slipped into the heads and
the tails of scenes as we all understand
how movies are made but the script was
yours and I could tell from the very
first read that it was a wonderful
script I have been listen I'm 53 years
in this business and something like this
does not plop into your lap only once in
a great while and this is surely the
best role that I have ever had dropped
into my land also in your acceptance
speech you said that you know it was so
validating to be recognized for your
writing because it helped with the fear
and you said that fear is the Grinch who
stole creativity do you feel like now
maybe that Grinch has been beaten back a
little bit no no no is it ever I just I
don't know you guys tell me is it ever
gone the fear feeling like you blew it
or feeling the fear of like oh no if I
take this step I didn't I don't know the
fear is every morning I wake up too
terrified it's just that I think this
making this movie from me felt like a
giant coming-of-age and I part of the
what I talk about in this film is like
that you come of age at every
there's not one coming-of-age at 17 I
don't think I didn't know anything at 17
I don't know anything now so making this
movie definitely felt like a
coming-of-age and just I think one more
young and we don't we're new in this
creative landscape there's such a
mysticism around Hollywood right now and
the sense that we don't belong and I'm
not sure that ever goes away but this
helped me for sure just run into the
face of that right like just face fear
its courage is the answer not
fearlessness Robert you've been at this
a long time what do you think about
managing the fear of creating and being
a part of things like this in 1968 I
worked with Gregory Peck on a picture
that's 50 years ago right now and I had
I asked him a couple of questions I said
how do you get into the Academy he was
the president of the Academy I think at
the time and he said you need more
credits and I said and how do you pick
material and he said you know when I was
a young actor I did not know the answer
to that and I asked a couple of actors
that I knew he said I asked Montgomery
Clift who said you do not take
everything they offer you you are very
careful about what you select you think
about it you feel it you live it through
you sleep on it you take your time and
you do not rush into something and
Gregory Peck said and you know I also
asked Gary Cooper how do you pick
material and Gary Cooper said you do
everything they hand you you never stop
working and you never pass up a day's
work and and Gregory Peck said and in
general they both had about the same
number of hits so it doesn't matter how
you do it only once in a great while
does something this could drop into your
lap I've said that before and it's true
and in Gregory Peck
then several years five years later was
my sponsor into the Academy so I was
yes I'm mighty grateful to be a member
of this organization thanks for being
here
thank you so much